welcome back everybody to love wha look
Wow
don't worry about what's happening here
oh it says these are programmable lights
for every blink for every blink you get
really really happy roll the intro leave
your entries in the sir ready pros maybe
you should sing a nice episode of why
everyone's favorite show when it still
makes love coming out see now it's out
now welcome everybody to YouTube's
favorite show fly where I go through
funny pictures and go haha that you guys
made human guys make the picture this is
the show where I ask the questions and
you guys do the answers this is the show
where I make the original content and
you give me the answers oh this week we
got a lot of great ones my god i-i've
been sneak peeking don't tell anyone
another chair meme everybody clap clap
hey old school bro so remember mr. chair
this is him now feel old yet well it
damn oh this is someone else's setup
that looks like my old setup daddy that
confused me well done hey look at that
someone paid 399 oh it's almost like
people can actually afford the chair and
you're just a crybaby can your chair
through this
I don't think so
$300 look at this look at these
crybabies I can't even get to one meme
from an who's texting me I have no
friends $300 for a chair that's not
typically the amount you would pay have
you completely lost touch with reality
yes I know
but can you do you don't see me oh man
for looks amazing in the New Avengers
infinity war movie that's right I am
actually Swedish unlike Chris Hemsworth
fakes Whiston Felix should make a pity
pie phone you smartphones think you're
so great huh but can you do this why is
this the only Mickey
[Music]
Wow alright here we go we have a girl um
yeah this happened all the time back in
the day of course faithful Christian
2013 pills equals based pewds
I have something in my tongue
[Music]
oh that is so cute
I think Edgar would have a great role in
getting over can we get an Edgar modpack
for getting over it that's awesome I
would love to see that
kawaii destiny which one doesn't belong
the star the bear the polka thing that's
right you don't hang the star oh that is
edgy let's put you a side little guy all
life is precious
did you just assume my gender
it's by cook making dankmemes now what
is this what is happening I've seen this
one it's it's a top notch top notch meme
good job whoever reposted this Congrats
what do you want a medal 1997 don't sit
too close to the TV it will damage your
eyes 2017 yeah I do feel like oculus
must mess with your eyes right there's
no way you can be healthy why am i
discussing this on the wine no one gives
a [ __ ]
hey Monica hey on you Monica when you
realize your favorite youtubers finally
last it's a good song okay I getting
trans every time I sing it you know the
other countries have their national
anthem switched in channel has hey hey
Monica hey today Monica found Felix
headquarters sorry sir
this is a Christian building so no
swearing oh it's my headquarters yeah of
course wait then lush sucks do like why
didn't oppose this one come on man
even Phil that my beard so nicely lush
sucks your ear the bass people doing
cool stunts with wheelchairs oh wow
that's pretty good why why
so good 8 out of 10 very nice 5 out of
10 needs more crippling depression
Christian channel depression is not a
joke okay
just look at this nuts hey bro are you a
gamer too this phone is perfect for
gaming there listen where's my phone
it's a great phone for gaming getting
over it with PT pi this game hard yeah I
will beat the game you guys don't
understand
you keep saying oh you should you should
quit the hardest part happens an even
begun this is not me playing getting
over it this is me turning into my true
form my god like form my same team being
I'm charging my chakra Peter PI act his
new getting over at gameplay video I am
bad at this game my mouse pad is small
okay you think
looks like someone's got a new trick up
his sleeve
[Music]
no more small mouths Pepe's this time
thank you nurse sir you've been in a
coma for three minutes
oh hey I already missed the captain the
last you laugh you lose
got passed with no problem I've never
seen anything like it I was like this is
a miracle this is a Christian miracle I
thought it would unlock something you
know like a forbidden forbidden ability
like your videos will oppelo just fine
but no no we won't
silently staring through the camera
answered the door what am I gonna do not
answer the door
bleh my editors okay oh yeah your editor
was so good Felix who edits your videos
oh yeah okay I need to open the door
they leave it in oh they're so great
[Music]
I'll do one weird thing off-camera
and I tell them hey don't put this in
they put it in why is everyone against
me I am the strongest man in the world
but can you do this I bet you he can't
don't say you love the anime if you
haven't read the manga excuse me
I am the visual novel adaptation get it
right they never do look like their
profile pictures tinder versus reality
am I doing this right
roses are red violets are blue when they
say you're out of contents got to do for
that we are now entering the last page
of memes this is where the good stuff is
this is the top of the salt mine but
where are the armrests huh and the
lumbar support finally you get it me
okay you cool Jesus Christ nice nice I
really appreciate the creativity that
comes out of petting dog memes that is
it is at the end of the end of the line
it's a dying bloodline of memes but
every once in a while you see your nice
one and you go huh why PewDiePie has 58
million subscribers because he's the
only two can do this goddamn right rest
in peace lick B that is so cute he said
would Steve the Hermit and all the other
memes now everyone's pressing F for
respect
o if you were a full-time youtuber what
type of content would you make on your
channel ask reddit nice try babe
well done to get those this week Oh
leave your entries in us already close
an episode post some memes for next week
and you can you can have the honor of
being immortalized in that PewDiePie
video you can put that on your
curriculum I was featured in PewDiePie
is video world's largest subscribing
channel not a dying Channel thank you
very much okay and remember to leave a
like and have a smile
[Music]